[Music]
okay so we're gonna start in the next
session we're starting this session with
a featured talk this is an invited talk
from a local of researcher in the in
this practicing the field and today
we're gonna have Mike Dodds from Galois
talking about continuously verified
cryptography hey so I'm a principal
scientist at Galois and so I want to
just to sort start out by talking a bit
about what Galois is because I feel like
we don't have as much visibility in this
community as as you know as I would like
so Galois is a research and development
lab we started out in Portland we've got
sort of three locations there's about 70
people there there's a really ridiculous
number of Piell people in Galois row at
the moment I think it must be sort of 40
or 50 so it's really a very large number
of people and we sort of really we're
kind of like a PL meets applications
kind of a shock really so lots of
programming languages lots of analysis
lots of verification lots of security in
crypto and we tend to use these kind of
things so symbolic execution and mobile
checking a history is really in Haskell
so I found there was a guy called John
launch brie who was like very
influential in the early sort of Haskell
design of Haskell but we also we've also
kind of branched out into all sorts of
other programming languages as well so
and just to give you an idea of the sort
of people who work there my background
is I was a professor in the UK mostly
interested in separation and concurrency
relaxed memory and so like I suppose
that you know this is I'm going to be
completely honest with you
we're recruiting in the moment so you
guys should apply but any basically
anybody who anybody who sort of would
write a pop of paper or peel the eye
paper or a cough paper totally welcome
Ogawa so you know we do a lot of kind of
that kind of research the sales pitch
aside I'm going to talk a bit about
continuous verification which is a very
cool project which actually I was mostly
not involved with so I'm going to talk
about other people's research today so
actually the people who did this we're
these awesome group of people I think
there are a couple of them missing off
here because I couldn't find pictures
particularly fire and cook over the far
side there in his group at Amazon and a
whole bunch of people in in Galway
including Aaron Toma yesterday and Eric
Mullen who did some awesome stuff
who is around here somewhere so let me
just kind of give a bit of contact
something that I find very exciting is
that static analysis tools are starting
to get out there into the real world and
people are starting to use them in
software development workflows and
that's very very cool so Google starting
to use the tool called error-prone so
they run that on pretty much every
commit that goes into their into their
repository first with Facebook or also
they have this magnificent tool called
infer which I'm very happy to say as a
separation logic tool it makes me very
very sort of warm and fuzzy inside to
say that and Amazon have this tool as
well which is what I'll talk about today
which is using a tool called saw so this
is really part of their code quality
process so really the thing I wanted to
distinguish is really that they're doing
it as part of their DevOps process and I
don't know how much Microsoft is doing
but let's say we can talk about that
okay I feel like I apologize the
motivation here is really they want to
sort of improve code quality they want
so kind of and so there are lots of
things that companies do to improve code
quality they have revision control and
testing and peer review and big
companies are just starting to you
static analysis as part of that pipeline
so that's pretty cool like programming
languages ideas analysis ideas are
getting out there so the thing that
Galois got into was the outers amazons
verification amazon amazon verification
story and so this is something where
we're doing proofs of correctness
reading on core infrastructure and we'll
doing it using a symbolic execution tool
called saw now I'm going to tell us I
don't now have to explain to you why TLS
is important but we're doing something
on a only on an implementation of TLS
this is a bit different in flavor from
Everest because instead of having a out
from sort of from start first principles
implementation of TLS we're going to go
to Amazon's existing tealights
implementation and prove them things
correct about it so Amazon's TLS
implementation was really inspired it
so kind of it's a new implementation but
it's not designed particularly for
verification so it was inspired all the
horrible vulnerabilities that people
have found finding and so it drops some
of the insecure and less secure features
it's much smaller it's only so for
example open SSL is 70 K lines of code
and s21 is only 6 K and the component
I'll talk about verifying today is H Mac
which is the keyed hash message
authentication code implementation so H
Mac is really the thing that provides a
signature for the message when you're
sending it over TLS so it's beef to your
fantasy authenticity and integrity and
actually the really nice thing about H
Mac that makes it very amenable to
verification is that the specification
itself is really tiny this is pretty
much what you see in the RFC the RFC is
like a bunch of kind of like boilerplate
sort of discussion and there's like one
line of math which tells you what age
mac does and so that makes it that's
very good from us that means we can kind
of write it down and so what we'd really
like is to sort of take this H max
specification which is concise and
easily auditable and we'd like to
connect it to the C hm a complement
ation which is fast and durable it's
also got some structural differences
from the way that H Mac is defined here
and so here's the summary of the
approach we're going to write a formal
specification we're going to write some
scaffolding to bridge that gap and then
we're going to use some tools and then
we're going to increasingly we're going
to integrate into the CI development
environment so the first step is to
write a formal specification so it turns
out that because we've already got a
specification language for crypto we can
just write it down pretty much straight
off so here's the you know roughly sort
of the formal specification and here's
the specification encrypt all which is
galaz specification language and you can
see that it's they're very sort of you
know modulo syntax they're pretty much
identical so that means that we can use
this we can also use this to do things
like generate tests we could use it to
synthesize code those are two things
that we've done with crypto in the past
but in this case we're using it to
verify existing code so now we want to
connect the hmx specification to the c h
mac and that's kind of more of a
challenge because we want to sort of
know that the we really want to kind of
like know that these two things really
do the same thing so we're going to have
to build some
yeah holding to bridge that gap because
there's a too big a gap just to do this
off you can't forgive this just kind of
part of the proving the proof process so
we're going to do this by layers of
abstraction we're going to have
high-level crypto code then we're going
to have some low-level crypto code that
sort of mirrors the structure of the C
code and then we're going to have some
production s to encode and when we get
to this point we're going to incorporate
estro and data structures and the SQL
api and we're going to emit some gnarly
features like pointers and memory
allocation low-level optimizations so
once you've kind of got this pipeline
once we've kind of built our high-level
spec a low-level spec in the s2 and it
can I see there's the s21 we're then
going to want to kind of actually show
that those two things are related to
each other so the tool we're going to
use is something that Galois have been
using for a very long time which is a
tool called the software analysis
workbench it's really a symbolic
execution tool so roughly you can think
of it as saying you take I think you
take artifact and another artifact and
you turn them both into sort of SMT
things and then you compare those two
things together you so use symbolic
execution to build those kind of SMT
comparable things and then we can just
sort of check it in SMT solver and so
then we kind of I should say by the way
one way that crypto code is generally
sort of get away with making our lives
easier is in this case all of this
crypto code doesn't have loops in so
we're just talking about luke free code
so that we saw and it tells us whether
it's correct or not and then we're going
to then once we've done that proof we
want to integrate it into the Devon
development environment and so that
means that we want to have continuous
integration now why do you want
continuous integration well you want it
so that nobody makes any mistakes so you
don't new mistakes to be introduced into
the system so we've set it up so that
the proofs run automatically on the code
changes so that means that when you
commit a piece of code then you can't
commit it to the repository if it
doesn't part if the proofs don't pass
and the proofs are independent of the C
code to PI they just depend on the
interfaces and that's because you're
compiling both the code and the
specification down into this SMT
representation which you then basically
you're using the SMT to compare and the
proofs are you know reasonably easily
adaptable I mean you know this is kind
of obviously sort of a somewhat movable
but we're not talking about
of having to do like a proof in
order to kind of like get this to go
through if the function body changes
it's very likely they're going to be no
changes to the proof and that's because
you're just sort of shuffling the
internal change behavior of the code if
the interface changes you're going to
have to change the proof but it's
probably not going to be too big and if
the core structure changes there are
going to be some small kind of changes
around the edges and then we've got you
know and this is very very nice so we
kind of integrated it into Amazon Web
Services CI system so what that means is
that every time you commit something to
s 2 n it runs the build and the build
sort of tells you that I pass the that I
pass the pass the tests and so that
means that what we would do we on like
nine hundred commits no not not that
many how many commits are we all now I
don't remember it's at least in my it's
around a thousand probably or something
yeah it's around a thousand commits or
something so there's passed so that may
not be that may just be for the whole of
s to end though but yeah it's but yeah
so the and so kind of all this stuff
kind of runs and it means that late you
know if you tried to commit something
that would violate one of these violate
one of these proofs then you would need
to then you would get an error and you
won't be able to commit it so when you
say independent so you don't have like a
loop answer or anything so when the
structure of the code changes if you had
a loop invariant you might need to
change yeah yeah that's right yeah so I
mean if you wanted to I mean this is
very you know the idea with this whole
thing is to kind of like focused on a
really kind of core critical code and
then just kind of like simplify as many
of the issues as possible but there are
some sort of there are some situations
where Saussure doesn't really do loops
so it's it's just it's just doing sort
of customized yeah yeah exactly yeah so
it's kind of it's so the reason that we
so actually I'll talk about this in just
one second because actually the whole
pipeline is a bit more complicated than
what I mentioned here we have a cap
paper which will be at curve 18 and so
down this end we've got sort of proofs
with saw and mostly automatic at this
level here we've got the incremental API
so what that means is it's kind of got a
bit more structure and it's actually
allowing you to do things like kind of
keep
adding messages and then kind of
finishing up so to do this connection
between the monolithic and incremental
API we need a little bit of kind of
to do this sort of induction and then up
here we've got proof serve
indistinguishability from random and to
do that
we have a connection between our
high-level specification and some work
that Lynette behringer and other people
did on on sort of proving the H Mac like
the crypto specification of H Mac is
actually correct in terms of its
high-level security properties so we so
gal wouldn't just do this we did drbg we
did TLS handshake protocols as a state
machine proof and we're working on some
of the rest the rest of these things so
so corrective parsing for various kind
of issues so basically the work is kind
of ongoing with this I mean I think that
Amazon you know the way that we approach
this is that we want to kind of pick the
high value sort of cases first am I
about to get kicked off until you're
making a sort of ominous kind of face I
see anyway yeah this kind of thing is
feasible which is very exciting and it's
also kind of it's also kind of it's also
something which is kind of I think
becoming more acceptable it's something
which is becoming kind of applied in
sort of context which aren't Microsoft
which are of course ahead of the curve
on this and it's which were sort of
raised now I've been being applied in
industry so it's kind of this lots of
exciting stuff going on in this area I
think ok right well I think the speaker
[Music]
it's great to see these back-to-back
talks really looking at the theory and
the reality of sort of how to do this at
scales is really wonderful work let's
have a couple questions Nick how do you
boil the TLS handshake in to do a free
code every to talk about this so it's
it's just proving that the there's one
function that that handles a single
state routine transition and we're just
proving that that always takes a state
to a legal successor state so that
function itself doesn't have any loops
in it it just gets potentially called
from higher level and what do you prove
of the whole country so we're just
proving that that function matches this
thing so we don't prove anything so far
we wonder the question what is the
business case for Amazon to implement
something like this in their pipeline is
it quantified in terms of number of bugs
that are causing downtime or I think
that they I well I mean I can't speak
for Amazon I think that I think that
what I hear from talking to people in
industry is that they're interested in
sort of they are primarily interested in
avoiding bugs instead of increasing
assurance I think that there's a lot of
people in an industry who in the
industry who are interested in sort of
like moving faster as well it's a coin a
phrase so they want to sort of reduce
the amount of kind of assurance that
they have to do for these kind of
systems and you can imagine that for
something like TLS you know you would
like to kind of be able to develop it
rapidly or rapidly kind of patch it and
if you have a sort of if you're going
through the normal kind of like sheron's
process that you would have a very long
kind of process to be sure that the
system was correct but I think that
these kind of tools are really about
kind of allowing people to kind of like
be more confidence in the way they kind
of commit which is an interesting kind
of switch of mindset between I suppose
the kind of light maybe safety critical
applications of formal methods where
really the whole point is to kind of
achieve a very very high level of
assurance and somewhere like I don't
know so somewhere like Facebook or
Amazon or Google where really what they
want to do is sort of do as little
assurance as possible but still achieve
good quality code so I think that
there's kind of maybe different to
difference in mindsets I think I think
that's kind of my broad understanding of
why these kind of tools got any more
uptake okay and with that we'll have to
defer more questions but let's thank the
speaker again all right our next speaker
is Sarah Chasen's from UC Berkeley she's
a little bit a little bit far not
exactly local but she she collaborates
with Ross public and she's gonna be
talking about Helena web automation
language hi everybody I'm Sarah I'm
gonna go ahead and actually start by
talking about how many people want data
that they won't collect off the web and
I think it's a ton right now but I think
it's gonna be even more going forward
and in addition to this difference in
scale I think the composition of the
folks who are interested in this is
going to be changing so right now the
people who have the tools to access web
data it's mostly going to be people who
can code but going forward I think a lot
of non coders are getting interested in
this stuff but I'm gonna go through a
couple examples so these are all
examples from our current social science
collaborators basically these are
questions that they're asking based on
information that they can find on the
web there are a lot of different reasons
that the people I'm focusing on mostly
are social scientists and there are a
lot of different reasons why they might
want to collect these large datasets
from the web but there's not a lot of
support for them to do this so we are
breaking it down here into what the
coders can use or says what the non
coders can use there's a ton of stuff in
that coders box all the web scraping
libraries that you might already be
familiar with and in the non coders the
options are more limited so over here
you really need to be able to actually
reverse engineer that web page so you
have to understand the Dom internals you
have to understand how the web page is
actually interacting with the web server
that's the unifying thing about all of
these libraries and we can't expect non
coders to do that so for non coders you
have some options you can hire someone
who's actually gonna sit in front of
that browser and copy and paste stuff it
sounds crazy but it actually happens you
can hire a coder to use one of the tools
from the other box
another thing that definitely happens
but it will require some more resources
or you can use some of the the recent
programming by demonstration tools that
have come out and in particular I'm
going to be focusing on the tool that
we've built called Helena
so basically this is the structure right
in demonstration goes in program comes
out maybe the user interacts with the
program does some edits and then they
can use that to collect their data so
we'll do a really quick video demo here
basically the idea with Helena is that
you are going to demonstrate how you
would collect the first row of a
relational or a multi relational data
set so here we've opened up our Chrome
extension we're going to grab
information about the first author from
a list of authors and then for that
first author we're gonna grab
information about the first paper in
that authors list of papers that gives
us the whole first row that we want at
this point Helena is looking at the web
pages and trying to figure out if there
are any relations for which we might
want to repeat some things so it's
thought that we interacted with the
first author and it decided to add the
loop to go over all authors it's gonna
do the exact same thing for papers at
which point we have the full script we
can go ahead and run it and we're gonna
watch it actually happening over here in
the web page on the Left we will start
to see the data as it gets collected and
so at this point yeah now it's
collecting it so that's how we write a
web scraper by demonstration and we can
use this if we let this keep going this
is gonna run for three million rows so
this is really big data sets that we're
collecting based on really a pretty
quick programming example and hopefully
I can make the clicker work to get us to
the next slide yes okay so we gave this
to some programmers because we wanted to
see if this had some advantages over
more traditional web programming and we
couldn't exactly bring in our social
scientists and ask them to use selenium
so we compared the more traditional web
programming language selenium with
Helena and it turns out yes with Helena
we're getting time from first use to
successful tasks in about six minutes
and it turns out if you're trying to use
a more traditional web programming
language you're probably gonna time out
at 60 minutes unless you have prior
experience so we're getting a lot of
advantages basically though we then want
to go from just that first output draft
of the script to how can we make these
scripts which are gonna run for a long
time I mentioned three million rows
that's gonna run for hours and hours we
have to make them robust we have to make
them actually fast so we're gonna ask
these end users how do some things that
we wouldn't normally ask from the users
of an end-user programming tool so
in particular I'm gonna be talking about
skip blocks so I'm gonna start with a
motivating example we're working with a
team of sociologists and what they want
to do is every single night scrape all
of the apartment listings off Craigslist
in order to give this data to the City
of Seattle they have a contract with
them so we were wondering okay what's
gonna be the issue what's gonna be the
problem we thought it would be some
subtle algorithmic thing no it wasn't
anything like that it was that the
undergrad that they had running this
every night on his home laptop connected
to his home Wi-Fi in the middle of the
night the Wi-Fi would go out and in the
morning daf-2 started and would go back
and do all the same work again so that
was pretty annoying and then it turns
out that even when he wasn't getting
these these Wi-Fi failures we were still
repeating a lot of work just because of
how much churn there is in this data so
when you load up Craigslist it's
starting at the beginning of all the
results and then it's indexing into the
current list so by the time you get to
page 2 of your Craigslist data the
things that were the end of page 1 if
there have been new listings those have
already been pushed onto the head of
page 2 and you might end up going back
and restriping those and that's pretty
silly we don't really want to do that we
were wasting hours on that so what we're
gonna be talking about here are problems
like these problems that we as the
scraping script can't actually prevent
so the network is gonna go down
sometimes you're the computer that
you're running it's gonna crash
sometimes you're gonna have to be able
to handle failures gracefully one way or
another and then there's also data
changes we can't control what the web
server is going to do if it wants to
change the data it's gonna change the
data and we just have to be able to
handle that and then there are a couple
of other fun interesting problems along
the way so what if we want to do some
longitudinal data collection so we might
want that to be incremental right if
we've scraped three days worth of data
this week and it took three days to run
that script we don't want it to take
another three days to collect the new
data a week from now let's skip over the
ones that we already did and just get
what's new and also sometimes these are
just slow we've had scripts that will
run for a week that's pretty long we
might want to parallel wise and then it
turns out also that sometimes
rate-limiting that websites do is based
on IP and at that point you might want
to distribute it across multiple
machines this is an interesting pun side
problem so these are the sort of things
that we want to be able to handle and in
fact we want our end users to be able to
handle it so we have a lot of
constraints on what they can do but we
also want to make these really robust
scripts
so basically even though these look like
really different problems all we really
want to be able to say is just don't
repeat the same stuff that you've
already done
now it's complicated to say what is the
same stuff right because as I just said
the data is constantly changing on the
web you can't expect it to remain the
same you might get a different set of
objects you might get objects that have
their attributes changed so how do we
actually say what's the same what we're
actually gonna do is ask the user to
introduce introduce a construct called
the Skip lock and that will be used to
actually tell us how to tell whether two
objects that we are seeing in different
places are in fact the same object and
also to associate the code that will
actually operate over that object and so
basically the idea is that we will keep
a commit log and if we have already seen
an object that has those key attributes
that tell us it's the same object that
means that we can go ahead and skip it
the next time we see it and if we have
never seen it before then we'll go ahead
and execute that associated code so the
good thing about this is that the user
does not have to reverse-engineer the
Dom the server interactions any of that
stuff they're just reasoning about the
output data which they already know
about and think about so basically
here's sort of the texta fied
representation of that same authors and
papers program that we talked about
before let's go ahead and add a skip
block into this so here what we're
saying is if you have already seen an
author that has the same name and the
same institution as an author we've seen
in the past that means you can go ahead
and skip it that's just assume that's
the same one don't bother to do that
code again so basically here are the key
attributes the author name the author
institution that's what we're using to
tell us whether it's the same object and
then we have the block of code that
actually operates on it so this is a
durable log this is not just a per run
sort of a situation so when we come back
in a week and try to research the same
author we will know to skip over this in
any run that I've bolded here that's the
default behavior obviously that's
something that we might want to
manipulate so though that's a fun and
interesting side question so basically
how we tackle all of those disparate
problems with this one thing so
extrinsic failures basically if the
network goes down and we have to restart
let's just skip over all those ones we
already did pretty straightforward there
for data changes same deal if we're
getting repeated objects because of how
much Craigslist is updating its fresh
data we can just skip over that when we
see it for longitudinal scraping this
will automatically incremental eyes so
everything that we scraped this week we
have to scrape it again when we come
back to it a week later because it's in
the commit log if it's just slow each of
these skip blocks each of the individual
objects identified actually ends up
being an independent subtasks so we can
distribute that across parallel workers
and if we're handling CAPTCHAs then we
can just do that across different
machines so there are a lot of fun
design questions about how we should do
these Skip blocks I'm not going to be
able to tackle most of these today but
definitely come talk to me I think one
of the really fun ones is how should we
split those independent subtasks a bunch
across a bunch of different parallel or
distributed workers it's a really cool
design problem I'm gonna go really
quickly over a couple of results so this
one's mostly just interesting because it
highlights just how much data changes on
the web it turns out that just in a
single run if you add these skip blocks
you can get up to about 2x speed-up just
because there's that much new data
coming in all the time so I thought that
was interesting this is what we see if
we parallel eyes you can see we're
getting pretty close to the ideal line
with the exception of this Twitter
benchmark which ends up being CPU bound
turns out if you load a thousand tweets
into a page it gets to be a really big
page and it's a lot to process but if
you actually distribute out this was on
a single machine if you actually
distribute that across multiple machines
then you get right back to that ideal
line so it gets to be exactly what you
expect and what we also looked at
whether our end users are non programmer
identified people actually can use this
and the answer is yes so we kept the
reasoning for this construct it's such a
high level that end users can learn how
to use it people who tell us that they
are non programmers can learn how to use
it in seven minutes and they can add an
additional skip buck each new skip lock
that they might add to their program in
about a minute 61 seconds so we're very
satisfied with those results
and with that I would love to take any
questions
we have we have pampered questions
generally useful concepts how would you
report this into more general-purpose
language yeah so we actually we spend a
while thinking about how would we put
this in like a Python script or a Python
you know if they're using selenium or
some other library to do their own
scraping in a more traditional way we
looked at how we could do that it turns
out it's not that hard I mean it's a
pretty straightforward concept as long
as you've hooked up everything you need
for keeping that durable commit log
you're pretty much okay
so who are you partnering with you said
that you were partnering with people
that are non programmers yeah yeah we
have about at this point it's between
eight and ten teams of social scientists
who are collecting a bunch of different
data with this it's really funny so so
how has that shown up in the
publication's do you have sort of the
experience report really do it so those
benchmarks that we showed were basically
tasks that we took from from their
target tasks but we haven't done sort of
the experience report I think there
might be a question to reason about skip
blocks the same way a computer science
program would you know what would be
interesting is for that I don't know if
it's exactly the same way so the way we
explained it in the basically the
tutorial that we gave them that took
them seven minutes to go through was
sort of to think about if you were
seeing sort of the output row that
represented each of these objects what
would you use to decide if two of them
were the same so that was how they were
thinking about I don't know if that's
the same way that a programmer would
think about it that is a really
interesting question I would would love
to study that question here considering
that you're doing with CAPTCHAs on the
fact that probably this is semi
adversarial relative to the websites and
so forth and also that you're running a
CPU skilling problems do you have a
variant of this where he is you
essentially fire it out to a bunch of
cloud machines and
yeah yeah turns out it's really easy to
put this on yeah yeah yeah yeah we do
we're some beautiful just we figure it
on operated so there is more of this
sort of setup work I think it's
definitely gonna be easier to tackle if
you are a programmer it's yeah getting
the AWS UI to work I was just gonna say
huh do you have any protections to
prevent people from you know who are not
programmers using the AWS burning to
DDoS hope you're not golfer I mean as
with any any programming tool this is
going to give people the option to write
programs that are bad their house on Web
Services credit cards right with that I
guess so say thank you again okay all
right so I have the pleasure to
introduce our next speaker
bill Zorn he's going to be speaking
about a concept called sinking point up
he if he can get his laptop to work okay
he's gonna be talking about sinking
point and I guess we'll find out what
that is
Bill's from UW and he's also my son so
yeah so thanks dad
so so today today I'll be talking about
sinking point this is a project that
I've been working on with Dan Grossman
who's my advisor and also a Zac Tatlock
now I think he's actually not credited
in the program because advisors have
been changing but anyway let's get right
into it so first let's talk a little bit
about good old I Triple E 754 floating
point
it's fast it's portable it's great
because it means that just about any
programming language these days is at
least as good as your ti-84 calculator I
Triple E 7.4 is completely specified
each operation is correctly rounded
which is to say we try to do it with as
much precision as possible and usually
this leads to behavior that's close to
the behavior that we would expect from
real numbers but sometimes not right and
it's a very well-known sort of challenge
with floating-point that reasoning about
when the behavior is like real numbers
is is hard so to give some concrete
examples if we fire up a good old Python
we import math and we run an expression
like this so here I've got pi obviously
I'm adding and subtracting the same
number two pi so I should get PI back
right which is four if I want to do
something slightly more complex like say
I you know in algebra and I need to
solve the quadratic equation here so we
can put in some arguments for for a B
and C and get X and we'll see that as we
make a very small keeping BNC the same
our result seems to converge to negative
C over B but as we become even smaller
then we'll see it starting to diverge
again and then eventually we find that
there's a zero at zero so to put this on
a graph right the this blue line is the
nice beautiful Mathematica function that
we would expect for X as a function of a
keeping B and C the same those black
points are the behavior from I Triple E
475 for floating point that we saw from
the points on your previous slide if we
think about this in terms of the actual
parabola right so here's with relatively
small a where remember we're solving for
the zero so the the zero crossings what
our floating point results seemed to
indicate is it as we make a smaller our
parabola is going to become more of a
line and eventually some five four says
that if we make if we were just to make
this line a little bit straighter event
would go through the origin which which
isn't isn't isn't right so here's
another really fun function this is sine
of 2t X as we get further from the
origin the two to the X part will grow
faster and faster so the wave will
oscillate faster and faster I Triple E 7
pi/4 it's actually pretty good at
evaluating this with doubles so for 15
we get the right number for I don't know
20 5.3 we get about 8 digits that are
right if we give it a ridiculously large
number like say 60 well actually get all
the bits right which is kind of
astonishing because if we deviate from
an integer even slightly we'll get a
result that is completely uncorrelated
with what we would expect the real
function to do right so um surprisingly
none of these examples are surprising
right
floating point is fully specified it's
just doing what the specification says
all floating point results I mean all
floating point numbers have the same
amount of precision all results of the
same procedure and it's it's it's left
to the programmer to determine if those
bits are actually meaningful and
correspond to the behavior of real
numbers so I mean if you're a if you're
a numerical methods guy writing you know
something in labelled this is probably
fine because you can afford to spend a
lot of time reasoning about your code
but in the general case where we just
want to do real arithmetic this seems
kind of troublesome the idea of sinking
point is that rather than giving back
all those meaningless bits all the time
we will actually dynamically reduce
precision right we're not going to be
any more accurate than i triple e 7 5 4
but the precision you do get will
correspond to actual behavior of real
numbers rather than whatever the
floating-point format said happens in
these weird cases right and the cool
thing about this is that we can do this
with very little overhead so we only
need to keep around a few extra bits we
only need to do a few extra bitwise
operations if you for example built in
the hardware I think that it could go
just about as fast as I should police
n54 floating-point so let's go back over
the same examples um here's what Python
said what python really meant here by 4
was like 4.0 oh oh oh oh oh oh right
exactly 4 there's a 53 bit significant
it's all zeroes if we do the same thing
with sinking point we still get 4 the
answer is 4 but this is saying you know
for twiddle approximately 4 I'm not
going to give you any more bits here
because I don't know what they are and
if you use this few bits to represent PI
4 is actually the best you can do so
this this number makes sense right
if we go back to our car daddy formula
here we can see that a lot of our digits
are totally bogus with sinking point we
won't even give you those digits and we
also have an interesting notation here
so this is zero at some exponent zero
can't have precision it doesn't have a
significant but it can have an exponent
and if you have an inexact zero with
some exponent what that really means is
like this is a number it's small I don't
know what it is but it's less than its
absolute value is less than two to that
exponent so this is a huge exponent
right we're saying a small number that's
less than to the fourth that's not a
very encouraging zero for our parabola
right and then meanwhile I'm cheating a
little bit here because if you see a
real zero it will actually give you zero
I'm cheating because since B is two we
can actually do the square root and
stuff exactly if we were to put in like
B is two point one and get an exact
result we would see zero with an
exponent but rather than being like four
it would be like you know negative 48 so
it seems like that result is much more
encouraging if you really have a zero
there rather than I don't know somewhere
between you know negative 10 and time
again with sine we can see that in all
of these cases we chopped off not all
the bits but most of the bits that are
bogus
what's cool here is that a sinking point
is actually smart enough to understand
that 60 is a special case because we can
compute that exponent exactly
it won't chop off any bits when they're
good but in the cases where your
function gives complete garbage it will
just punch and say oh I don't know what
sine isn't in that range there's no
precision right so how does this work
um you've probably learned I carefully
send for five for floating-point
rounding at least once in your life I'm
gonna go over it again hopefully quickly
and a little bit differently than you've
seen before so if I want to represent a
real number with bits I can do that with
some integer significant times two to
some exponent right so you know 5min
quarter is twenty-one times two let's
define two quantities we have P which is
the number of bits in the significant
this pretty straightforward is just the
precision and then we also have this
quantity that I'm going to call n which
is the exponent minus one so you can
think of n like if this number is exact
you can think of n as like the index or
like the place
the the most significant bit whose value
I don't know so all the bits below and I
don't know what those are and those are
my numbers exactly which case they're
zero right and what's cool about these
concepts is that we can actually use
them to like explain how I Triple E 754
rounding works so for like for doubles
we choose some maximum P and we choose
some minimum n53 and negative 1075 and
we say an order for round into a double
if I have bits past my max P or bits
with significance below my minimum n
around those bits off and so that
minimum n is not a random number it's
actually the minimum exponent that the
double can haves - the precision and
what's cool about this is that like sub
normal numbers just fall out naturally I
don't have to do anything special
subnormals they all have the same N
we're just letting the high bits of the
significant go to zero right so for
that's I Triple E 754 for sinking point
what we're going to do is actually
determine what these values should be
dynamically per operation so that we get
rid of the precision that we don't know
how to compute right so we need to come
up with some rules for addition and
subtraction we're actually going to be
bounded by n if I have two numbers and I
have some low bits and one that I don't
know if you think about it if I add more
bits over top of those bits I'm not
magically going to learn what those bits
are right the granularity of the number
that I know to the least you know like
like absolutely place is the granularity
the output so we'll take among our in
executive inputs choose the largest
value of n and use that as the rounding
for our art oh right and then we're
actually not really constrained by pker
so we can say like if we want to just
emulate I Triple E some type of our
floating point just use it over the
maximum it for the format is yeah so for
multiplication and division it's the
other way around we're not really
constrained by absolute n but we are
constrained by P so if I have two inputs
then the precision with result can't be
more than whichever in exact result had
less precision
and then hopefully powers and wrists
really multiplication this is still
being developed so maybe not well we'll
find out in testing for more interesting
functions floor is kind of cool because
the result is actually exact right as
long as I know I'm between two minute
if I have functions that are periodic
like f mod then my rules become more
interesting f mod is really a
subtraction right so we have like you
know X mod y it's the remainder so my
dividend is going to supply n because
I'm using it in a subtraction then the
other thing in that subtraction is going
to be my my divisor times some integer I
can get the integer exactly so I can
actually get the effect of using the end
from that multiplied divisor by taking P
this is kind of a you can talk talk to
me about it later and then sine is also
really fun with sine we're not bound by
n but our precision is actually bound by
the granularity with which with which
you know our input relative to the
granularity of PI so yeah so these are
these are the rules still work in
progress it's cool because these are
very simple rules and they can give us
some confidence that we have meaningful
precision without having to do a whole
bunch of real analysis or anything like
that no this is still an approximation
it's not a sound guarantee the idea is
that it should have relatively low like
false positives right if I say you have
bogus precision there's probably
something wrong in your computation
hopefully I won't in you know say any
point well not in most cases cut off
it's unnecessarily so this is part of a
larger project I'm working on called
Titanic which is a tool for building and
reasoning about systems by the way this
is this is neural style transfer this is
a neural network art yeah and also
thanks to Dan for that for the for the
for the titles his his his his health
has been very evident here so Titanic is
a tool for reasoning about and building
things like sink you point a knife a
police in a fight for floating-point I'm
also interested in other stuff like
reasoning about performance you know how
much accuracy can we throw a way to get
speed with and also exotic types like
whatever Google's doing in their new TP
use or I know Microsoft has fp8 which
looks kind of interesting and then I'm
also working on a few bench titanic'
uses this a nurse from EFI bench so
that's another cool project started by
favela and Zak and the Herbie guys props
to them but yeah talk to me about any of
these things
okay let's thank the speaker okay we
have some time for questions
seeking absolutely so when I say
specifically that like we're still an
approximation we're not trying to broad
a sound guarantee the sound version of
it would be interval arithmetic you
could imagine rapping sinking point in
something like interval arithmetic in
order to return rather than one of these
fast rules which is quick to compute but
not necessarily sound like an actual
interval arithmetic supplied guarantee
that already exists it's John Gustafson
is younam's essentially and the problem
is that with interval arithmetic you
have a lot of you know if you will false
positives for any large computation it
can be really hard to figure out what
the interval is right with sinking point
we're helping to you know do the
opposite thing we're fast rather than
sound and we have low false positives
rather than a sound right
oh yeah that's it that's a very good
empirically no but so that's that's the
main evaluation thrust here what I'd
like to do is have a large set of
benchmarks and go through and say look
here's the number here's the real result
here's the number of bits we give you
does it correspond to the place where
they differ and then I mean interval
arithmetic depending on the size the
benchmark would either give you no
information or you know also be
somewhere in there so okay one more
question yeah so there's there's a
really interesting question here I see
no reason why this can't be implemented
in hardware I mean I'm not a hardware
guy I don't like you know design adders
but it is kind of cool because as we
chopped precision off we can do less and
less work right there's also potential
for if you had a type that had a
variable sized exponent and significand
you could get much more dynamic range
from the same number of bits right
because you could have very small
significant numbers with the huge
exponent so yes there are certainly
considerations here and Titanic is a
general framework so it would be good
for reasoning about ways that we can
throw precision away in order to get
operations to go faster all right let's
thank the speaker again
so just a very brief anecdote about how
small our world is so when I started at
Berkeley in 1982 as a PhD student my
advisor was velvel Khan who is the
inventor of I Triple E floating point
and when I went into his office he had a
calculator and he would tell you I I can
show you calculus is much like we just
saw that don't work right correctly on
the calculator and he made that he
solved that problem you know for all of
us so that's a great benefit but it
shows you that these issues are timeless
and so you know just keep working on
them okay with that we're gonna
introduce our next talk we have the the
speaker Stewart Byrne Steiner and he's
going to be speaking about girlfriend
extraction with native types thanks
alright so I'm gonna be talking about
extraction of code from proof assistance
and so typically the way this is done is
you write some code in a proof
assistance such as you verify it
and then if you want to actually run
this code the way you do that is you use
a process called extraction which in
case turns your code into Oh
camel code and then you compile that
with the Oh camel compiler to get a
binary that you can actually run now the
downside to this approach is that it's
completely unverified the extraction
procedure is unverified the Oh camel
compilers unverified you link the thing
with an unverified runtime and so all of
those nice properties that you proved
about your program you don't
actually have any guarantee really that
they still hold onto executable that
you're actually going to run now more
recently there's been actually a couple
different projects working on verified
extraction for so there's F which
is what I'm gonna be talking about today
and there's also assert a I'll just
make some different trade-offs in a few
places but they have the same general
idea you take your code compile it
down to C or C like language and then
run that through concert which is of
course verified and oof insert a car
verified as well so you can be highly
confident that whatever program you
feed into this process the binary that
you get out is going to exist
the same behavior and this is really
nice there's a big improvement over
previous ways of getting sort of
verified binaries out of programs
so for example in 2015 and repeal I had
to do this extensive manual proof of
equivalence between a
implementation of sha-256 and a C
implementation which could then be
compiled with concert where I was with
something like if you can actually do
this translation automatically right it
will automatically compile the
version of shot 256 down to a C version
and it's guaranteed to exhibit the same
behavior but sort of not everything is
perfect here and so let's talk about
performance so if you run a C version of
shot 256 on this little tiny input it
runs and basically no time at all uses
two megabytes of memory if you run the
you've extracted a verified Chalk 236
binary on the same exact time you input
it runs for four seconds and uses three
gigs of memory so that's obviously
terrible so what's going on here and
this comes down to a question of data
representation so in the C version of
sha-256 when it wants to manipulate a
word of the input or of the sort of hash
state it uses a real 32-bit integer
you know it's four bytes in memory if
it's in a register right doesn't get
much simpler than that the extracted
version uses the integer type from the
standard library which is what was used
in the original implementation and
that implementation looks like this I
the represents integers as a linked
list where every node of the list
contains one bit of the number all right
and so this is clearly not optimized for
performance it has some nice properties
for reasoning but you know no one was
ever intending for this code to actually
be executed and of course is very slow
and uses tons of memory so what we would
oh and there's no reason that it needs
to be this bad right we're not working
with sort of unbounded integers or
anything wild like that inside of this
sha-256 implementation you know sha-256
the algorithm itself is defined in terms
of 32-bit words the Cauca implementation
uses this sort of refinement type it's
an unbounded integer but restricted to
the range 0 to 2 to the 32 there's only
2 to the 32 possible values of this type
and so we should be able to represent
this type it
time using a real 32-bit integer and so
that's the idea of the native types
feature specifically we want a way to
map types down to custom data
representations of the sea level so for
example we like to map that word type
from the shockula t6 implementation down
to C's int type just mapping the types
is not enough if you've ever worked with
you know custom extraction I sort of
changes in Cocke you know they just
mapping the types doesn't improve the
asymptotic performance of your
algorithms you'd also like to map
certain functions down to custom sea
level implementations such as mapping
addition mod 2 to the 32 down to you
know a real addition expression at the
sea level and then a couple other design
constraints when we were building this
feature you'd like to maintain all of
our existing correctness guarantees it
all has to still be verified and we'd
like to make it extensible to new types
and new functions and in particularly
the reason for this is that updating all
of these compiler correctness proofs is
a lot of work and we'd rather not have
to redo that work if you want to add new
types or new functions later so our
design for this is we did not want to
you just sort of add int as a new type
supported by the compiler since then if
we came back and wanted to add double
later on we would have to change this
definition further and you know this is
sort of used in basically every part of
the compiler after we do tons of proofs
again so we did instead as we added a
sort of generic native type variant here
as parameters by this native type
definition and this native type
definition is basically a big record
that contains all the information that
the compiler needs to know to compile
values or variables of this type and so
in particular for this you know sha-256
int case we have to give it a high level
representation of the type which is this
word type this is just a coq type as
used in the shockula t6 implementation
have to give it a low level
representation which is just C's int
type and then we have to prove a bunch
of llamas about the relationship between
these two types and just general
properties about the different
representations and the benefit of doing
it this way is that we can actually
define more of these native type
definitions as many as we want and no
matter how many of these we define we
never have to go back and touch that
type you know
ever again our approach to doing the
mapping of functions is very similar
instead of just adding explicitly a new
variant for integer addition we add a
generic one that supports any native
operation it's again parameterised by
one of these operation definition
records and takes some number of
arguments and I'm not actually going to
show you the native operation definition
record because it's actually much more
complicated than the one for types and
in particular it's more complicated
because it has to support the semantics
of every I are used in the compiler so
every IR that's used within the compiler
in the semantics for that IR there needs
to be some definition of what happens
when you step over a native operation
which means we need enough information
in the record to support all of those
sort of variants of this step relation
there are a couple different ways that
we could have done this what we chose to
do is instead of having sort of one
function in the record for every single
IR in the compiler we just have one
function for every single value
representation in the compiler and
there's many fewer of those than there
are different IR s now an advantage of
doing it this way is that it just
simplifies that the definitions of these
native types if you want to add a new
one you just have sort of less stuff to
write in that record it also simplifies
some of the compiler correctness proofs
so a lot of passes it turns out just use
the same value representation on both
sides and so when you get to the native
operation case of the sort of simulation
proof
it's basically trivial because the left
side and right side are doing basically
identical behaviors the downside though
is this doesn't give us a way to let
native operations call functions so for
example you couldn't implement map or
other higher-order functions as native
operations and the reason for that is
that different intermediate
representations even ones that use the
same value representation actually have
sort of slightly different ways of
representing program State or function
calls and so there's no way to sort of
provide all the necessary information to
do those function calls at every level
of the or for every I are within the
compiler the big downside of this is
that we can't implement recursive
eliminators as native operations so you
can't for example write a coq function
that takes an int and you'll run some
code for every value from 0 up to n
since I would involve calling a function
inside or you can write that function in
of course but you can't sort of
translate it as a native operation to
sort of for example a while loop in C
but you know we got all this sort of
working and it is pretty extensible we
were able to add not just int and
addition but we also added sort of all
of the normal arithmetic operators and
comparisons you would expect to see on
intz also some conversions such as
internet which converts to the Cox just
NAT type which is very commonly used we
also added the double type with the same
sort of arithmetic operations
conversions comparisons and finally our
sort of native types and operations do
support memory so we can define double
arrays which are heap allocated and some
operations on those you know you can
allocate them you can get and you can do
functional updates on the contents of
the array the proof of burden is not too
terrible it's 65 lines roughly for each
type definition and bit over 200 lines
for each operation and that includes
some groups of operations so for example
all binary arithmetic operators on intz
are basically the same and so you know
those only get counted once in this
average and finally in terms of
performance we got some pretty big
benefits from this so back on that shock
of every six example where previously we
were running for four seconds and using
three gigs of ram the version that uses
int I this much more efficient data
representation is much faster it's 50
times faster and uses 87 times less
memory and that's it
so I'll be happy to take questions
[Music]
[Applause]
all right questions so 87 times less
memory is really good but I know that
it's still 20 times more memory than the
C implementation so what's what what
would it take to go the next 20x yeah so
we haven't profiled it in sort of very
much detail but I think the main sort of
source of memory allocations is
allocating closures to make function
calls and a lot of those closures don't
really need to be on the heap because
for example you allocate the closure
make the call and then never use the
closure again so you could allocate that
on the stack but we've not implemented
that optimization yet questions how
tight is this - like targeting C versus
other language I not very it's just C
already has a verified compiler that we
could use as the backend and with that
as our back-end we of course chose you
know C types and such as the target for
the native types
in it free memory like if I have a
long-running application will I just
leak memory forever yeah so we don't
actually have a garbage collector I in
the you know I was gonna say that
runtime but if doesn't really have a
runtime so there's no garbage collector
which is I guess another contributor to
the high memory usage we do have some
sort of unverified like an unverified
slab allocator that can do some sort of
region based memory allocation so you
can know do some operation and when
you're done copy out the result and
throw away all of the intermediates that
are allocated but that's sort of as good
as it gets right now it's kind of a
little bit of any question but I think
one of the arguments you're making is a
reduction in TCB argument by saying you
can remove your camel compiler from it
isn't made mm-hmm but your camel
compiler is already in your TCB if
you're working with yeah but I see
that you're gaining something but I'm
not exactly sure how to pinpoint you
know exactly what the reduction in TCP
is yeah so our argument there is that
when you link the Oh camel compiler into
your extracted cut or the Oh camel
runtime into your extracted code you
have to rely on the correctness of that
runtime under every input that you feed
to that code whereas when you use the Oh
camel runtime as sort of part of your
compilation process or your your
verification process you only have to
trust it to run correctly on your code
the code that you're feeding through the
compiler I you don't have to worry about
what if you know I'm exposing this as a
web service and someone is sending me
adversarial inputs trying to break the
Oh camel runtime you're only feeding it
sort of code that you have written
essentially
all right let's thank the speaker
[Applause]